selon une étude récente de
l'observatoire national du tourisme la
fréquentation des lieux culturels
connaît une certaine érosion au profit
de parcs à thème ou de parise animalier
jean jacques dufour et philippe rey se
sont rendus à amboise visées de comparer
du traditionnel château et du nouvel
aquarium siéger par l'armée des parcs à
thème les châteaux résiste plus ou moins
bien versailles apparemment mal dépendu
aurait perdu un million de visiteurs en
cinq ans la dame ça n'intéresse pas du
tout est fatigué de trop d'histoires
lacets serait-ce à dire que notre
patrimoine culturel part en quenouille
la question se pose la réponse en tout
cas celle du conservateur d'amboise
rassurera les amateurs de vieilles
pierres
on nous pose de façon assez simpliste
les parcs à thème au monument est en
fait on s'aperçoit nous à amboise par
expérience que les clientèles sont les
mêmes et que le château fait venir
s'étendre le client qui vont ensuite
dans ce parc à thème soit mini châteaux
soit l'aquarium
etc l inverse c part qu'athènes nous
amène des visiteurs cela dit en 96 les
parcs récréatifs représentait déjà plus
de 55 millions d'entrées contre 32
millions de tickets pour les châteaux
architecture remarquable tonné dans le
val de loire
le parc des mini châteaux attire à lui
seul plus de quatre cent mille visiteurs
chaque année
ici les châteaux sont à l'échelle 1 25e
le tous de plain pied
pas une seule marche à monter pour
marquer c'est moins fatigant il est
ainsi en une seule fois
vous pouvez voir tous les châteaux du
val de loire surtout déplacés pour voir
l'aquarium qui est l'aquarium de
touraine les mini châteaux
au total ces deux parts compte attirer
l'année dernière plus de 900 mille
visiteurs autrement dit
sa benne les vieilles pierres elles
existent elles sont là certes il ne faut
pas les oublier
mais c'est vrai que la clientèle a
besoin d'apprendre beaucoup de choses
tout en s'amusant donc il est vrai que
ce genre de parc comme vous les avez vu
aujourd'hui son départ qui fonctionne
bien et qui font du maintien cela dit
vous n'allez pas croire que les
conservateurs des musées ou des châteaux
baisse les bras en tout cas celui
d'amboise fait face on est sur une
stratégie qui doit être affiné
nécessairement offensive
on a peut-être des aiguillons autour de
nous qui sont prêts à prendre notre
place si nous en laisse mais vraiment si
on se bat avec nos arguments et une
façon assez volontaire je suis certain
qu'on a une bonne marge de progression
encore dans l'avenir aller haut les
coeurs nos châteaux ont connu d'autres
assauts ils seront résister à mickey